you
all right flowmaster 925 four months ago
before his plastic surgery he looked
like Theo von you did look like Theo von
what's up on who Theo von has a podcast
and Shane knows who he is nothing like
this guy there's a mullet here's a
mullet but he has like the same nose
used to have hair parted down the middle
yeah kind of yeah the center hair fire
yeah funny could be could be I'll take
that that's a compliment there's worse
things to be compared to yeah good
looking disposed go ahead next Dan
Bowman three months ago
you think Becky spent the whole 29k on
more coke
Becky looks like she did a mess a whole
mess of coke I don't she never did coke
when she was really that no I find that
they had that not with me I don't know
the twenty nine grant what's 29 grand I
don't know I don't know where you got it
from I did cash a check one time I think
for 29 grand I don't know everybody
wants Danny to take a swig from the Jack
Daniel's bottle from the JD bottle yeah
okay straight out the bottle did anyone
give any money for it no but they're
dropping a [ __ ] ton of son emojis
someone can drop five bucks don't think
of swing somebody drop five bucks take a
swig what the heck he's a jukebox I'm
not you don't play for free my name's
not shoenice [ __ ]
alright next one I got one from Ben
Lynch and offski will Matt ever release
merch a shirt that says you're assuming
I'm Gary Sullivan the next merch line
should be mad cause commercial yeah we
could do a whole merch line you're not
doing that look at he's like he's
thinking out how can I make more money
yeah
collaboration t-shirt 1:1 collaboration
run collaborate you all the proceeds huh
well donate all the proceeds that's not
what Harry Sullivan
- Gary solo that years old as soon as we
figure out a so she won you know what
was Becky a freak Becky was the girl in
the first story the Bonnie and James
McKay bonnie bonnie lot that went on the
run yeah she was the winning short
blonde hair yeah yeah yeah people would
buy it
typical what Becky would look like boy
yeah looked like she did a lot of coke
people are into the merger I probably
could do I should and I've had multiple
people say you got to do a March account
you know yeah no listen I'm this it's
too much
listen this guy really I mean honestly I
you seem surprised
yeah I I don't know I don't know I I
guess I I guess I'm naive the first
night we did the one podcast and we went
out and and we went we went somewhere in
eight he Danny when I walked away he was
like the I remember everybody was like
so what was that guy like you know a guy
who said that just people were you know
Stacy or people that had watched so what
was Danny like so what was he like was I
was like he's really just a nice guy
like he started concrete like I kind of
thought he was kind of jerk you kind of
like a jerk
I said please died he's really a nice
guy and he he started this whole thing
just cuz he wanted to give people a
platform to tell their stories and you
know it's like it's not even his
full-time gig he just does it because he
likes it he really enjoys it this and
this you know and then you know he ever
since then I slow and my first
impression was we had somebody donate
some money for you to take a shot how
much money fifty and okay the hell's in
okay it's okay for you to take a
[Music]
and it's okay and it's okay you can do
it now did you skip the crab juice all
right man
brandy doc kitchen hey I want to know
what his opinions is on the current real
estate market in Florida we just had
this conversation I know and all this
[ __ ] is the same [ __ ] next move on no I
I read them all I got one all right
Pablo zero eight three two what's the
best restaurant you've been to on the
run
best meal was there a food snack fast
food that you've always went back to
even when your pockets were at the
fullest people have spoken no idea I
mean I there was a place we used to eat
at in Charlotte North Carolina we
beckoned I had a had an apartment
Charlotte North Carolina we owed it used
to eat at a place called the brick it
was it was great it wasn't like a
high-end I'm not a food guy I'm not like
it's not like I'm 150 dollars yeah bro I
like I love Waffle House I love a good
greasy spoon yeah I could eat scrambled
eggs and bacon for every [ __ ] meal
damn right and a fountain soda fountain
coke not Pepsi fountain kvitko it's
gotta be I mean I come on Scottie you
got a Coke no we got Pepsi zyc so you
don't got Coke yeah I'm Pepsi's there's
there's a huge difference I think big
difference yeah that's why it's two
different brain it's gotta be from the
fat was gotta but it's gotta be from the
fountain drink - so you like the
fountain better than the can of course
there's no comparison but what if like
the the ratio is off at a restaurant
we'll turn your water yes sometimes yeah
and and I and the fact that like I'll
notice that bothers me because I'm like
Frick are you the prick that goes hey
you know your syrup ratios long yeah
that's can I get some more guys back
like so who do you think has like a
perfect ratio consistently no I didn't
lose them but I don't think I just
barely but I've only not a few times
that's when when I get Danny to take off
up the money when he peels off yeah a
couple of dollar bills for ya
do you want to talk about start talking
about that now you want to open up that
can of worms what he said it hmm I'm
just having a conversation yeah rip one
our motto here we go Brian underscores a
mouse key can you please ask Matt if he
thinks the fraud was worth doing he had
to do prison time and has to pay it back
what does he think now looking back
same old not absolutely not worth it
wasn't worth it alright here's this one
and NFC power my girlfriend doesn't want
to stay with her mom because her mom
isn't a good influence nor a good mother
she's 17 and I'm 17 she lives with me
now the mom says she's going to report
her a runaway and have me arrested for
hoarding a runaway no human deserves to
be taken as a joke especially a young
lady how can the mother track us down if
she decides to and her phone location is
off what how can they get tracked down
if her phones phones off they're gonna
report her runaway they're on the run
fast story they're on the run their
house it lives with it how do they how
can they be tracked how many months ago
is that did me like they only have to
hold and say that it seems urgent this
was a 12 minutes ago it was a 12 minute
thing because I remember that was one of
the things I read earlier today yeah it
was on my history it says 12 minutes
right here yeah the screenshot
like how a contract I can't if I cannot
the FBI tracking phones they're on the
run in there throw their phones out of
the window watching right you know
waiting this question isn't gonna help
them you're just drawing more attention
to that they asked the question track
you down through your phone for a [ __ ]
and run away they're gonna fill out you
17 does it matter
FBI's not getting involved not for you
they're not popping you off cellular
towers is there anything like that
you're gonna fill out a police report
and if she gets caught by the police
doing something they'll run her name and
it'll say hey you're a runaway but you
have no contact with the police
you have to worry about you just be on
bud just chill out fine chill the hell
out this isn't a question but it's a
great comment listening to this guy read
is like watching so could you donate
some money so we can send Shane to the
burn war more beer 200-pound Hatrack
Matt I have a legitimate question so
since you've gotten out of prison what
have you been doing and what would you
suggest to somebody else who is trying
to take their credit score from really
shitty to really good so how do you how
do you go about how do you someone like
you go about building their credit score
and creating a [ __ ] 800s score I mean
that's the fastest way what's the
fastest way to build your credit score
it depends if you have no credit yeah
what was your guys what was your credit
like when you got out of prison
I had nothing zero I got three secured
credit cards and I made the minimum I
made that I really didn't put anything
on them like I got secured credit cards
I put up like 300 bucks and $400 and
$200 on three different ones
I kept the balances low after six months
and making payments BAM I had like seven
I think I'd like a 7:30 or 7:30 yeah
because it would have been higher but
you know
it will become higher if you keep them
below 30% so you you use 30% of your
ballast keep it below 30% of the balance
of the available balance right keep it
below 30% and then you just have to make
those payments and maintain it and the
longer you have that credit the more
history you have the higher your
squirrel go I'm 30% keep it a 30 below
30% what's your credit right now right
now I think it's still like seven
something like I I had a listen my car
what do you mean still like seven
something well cuz it was up it went up
there was like 747 50 and then it went
down like seven ten or seven was it ever
ate something no now ever since before
after I don't think it was never it was
always in the mid seventies mortgages
come and go and I buy a car and then six
month for eight months and trade it in
and get another car so you you're never
really having that that longevity
longevity longevity that longevity you
know that history on some best ways to
open them credit cards and just keep
making the payments keep below 30 right
right and then your Chryst of all you
you don't need an 800 credit score okay
the the minimums are like 650 like the
minimum scores like 650 you want to get
a better credit rating yeah okay in the
mid 700 s but very few people have a
Tundra credit scores it just doesn't
make a massive amount of difference in
your credit score